l'euphorie de la délégation française
après l'attribution des JO 2024 à Paris
[Applaudissements]
cette victoire il le savent il la doit
vont partir à un homme Tony Estanguet ce
triple champion olympique de canoë qui
semble devoir être auréolé de succès dès
qu'il s'engage dans une compétition
c'est vrai que c'était une sacrée
compétition quand même celle-là pour moi
c'était fort parce que pendant 20 ans
j'ai passé ma vie dans un canoë un peu
seul à relever des défis sportifs mais
dans un sport individuel même si on est
voilà il y a toujours un entourage
là ce que j'ai adoré dans dans cette
phase là de candidature c'est que ça a
été une petite équipe là très soudée et
on est allé chercher cette victoire
ensemble c'était magique
[Musique]